Malaysian authorities say about 40 ships and 22 planes...
...are aiding an intensive search for the missing Malaysia Airlines Flight 370.
The search has broadened to include land and sea off Malaysia's west coast...
...because there are signs the plane may have turned around.
Aviation safety experts say turning back at cruising altitude...
...is a sign that something may have gone wrong.
And the plane may have been trying to make an emergency landing.
Most plane crashes occur during takeoff or landing says Daniel Tsang,...
...an airline safety expert who spoke with VOA via Skype.
Although a large oil slick was spotted after a second day of searching,...
...there were still no signs of wreckage of the plane.
Wreckage debris could help shed light on what might have happened.
The revelation that at least two of the passengers were using stolen passports...
...and questions about the identity of two others has raised concerns about terrorism.
Malaysia's Transportation and Defense Minister Hishammuddin Hussein says...
...authorities are checking the names of those on board.
Analysts say the fact that two passengers got on board using stolen documents...
...will raise some difficult questions.
Malaysian authorities are reviewing security camera footage of the two individuals...
...who got on board with falsified documents.
Bill Ide, VOA News, Beijing.